there's a man who's been harassing me
for years
he's just so strong
and so much better
he goes by the name of Dillian the
hacker
but it looks like we finally defeated
him because he's made an apology baby
let's watch judging by this time well
you already know what this videos about
that's right [ __ ] you lost over the
last few weeks it said a lot of stupid
things yeah you did I made a bunch of
videos bashing PewDiePie yeah you did
but something happens it's not cool my
anything to hurt man and I can't do it
anymore
yeah that's right this is something that
didn't count on winners never grow but
haters never fail I mean haters quit and
winners [ __ ] you I knew that it would
get oh my God he's gonna cry you know
what I forgive him how long I haven't
done it I think we can put this behind
us so I want to apologize holder
visually apologize right here and now
you know what I forget I just want to
apologize to all of you in the broad
army who were born without breakups did
you seriously think that I would
apologize for anything I said seriously
I am NOT some teenage girl you will not
bully me off the internet yeah you are a
teenage girl daddy I am a hundred
percent cold Pilate did you actually
think anything you said on the Internet
wouldn't hurt my billing War This Means
War I am shaking so angry I'm shaking go
down let's see what else we got until an
expert happier wouldn't update is an
older video I have been messaging peopIe
over the last few days and he has
confirmed that he's afraid of me wait he
promised you promised we speak he's in
the process of making an apology you
wouldn't tell anyone
also I've been appointed as the business
management expert or being mean for PD
buzz channel this goes against our
contract
all content has to be approved by me Oh
show for it gets uploaded don't listen
to him don't know it's not true it's not
true I swear who do you trust this face
or that face
and I want to give special thanks to the
brown army in this hostile takeover it
wasn't for you if you do not give me all
this exposure for my channel then peopIe
wouldn't have even known who I was
so now thanks to you I've taken over
Peter Pan's Channel
no no another one
what'd I do this time you asked I stole
PewDiePie his girlfriend oh that's right
and the best part about it Peter vine
knows his girlfriend loves me more than
him no she gave us his blessings I did
not give him our blessing I did not give
blessing for him to marry Marcia
Marseille wanted to do it anyway
Judy by how dare you well someone hit
puberty I was once a hater PewDiePie
until he helped me reinstate my channel
that's right I did help him reinstate
his channel and everything changed
well it occurred to me that there are
still people posting lies about my
repute and this includes a rapper who
can you believe Rudy Prager please
posting lines of a beautiful thing he's
a child molester what is he talking
about what is he talking about not three
pack
no no not free pack
it's actually pretty good guys in good
shape I do not want to fight with him
but he knows the greatest that he just
rhyme rapists with greatest again I it's
over I lost I can't beat that you just
can't beat that
I ain't you beautifly I hate you that's
enough
Dylan the hacker I don't care if you're
seven T come to England again
fight me I'll fight you with these giant
muscles I will destroy you I will put
you in jail for what you did to me oh
I'm shaking again Dylan this is war are
you in or are you have I will send my
army of Broce to destroy you
you